thank you
colleague realize
foreign
the trilateral meeting
between
prime minister
blankovic Mrs Perez the president of
Slovenia and the president of the
commission Mrs funderline was just held
Mr Blair kovich will now address you
I welcome all of you I also extend a
very warm welcome to President Van Der
Lyon president Perez Musa who I
congratulate upon the beginning of her
term
in office and this is really a great
opportunity for her to join us here at
bregana and mark the beginning of
Croatia's accession and I also welcome
Mrs Suite vice president of the
commission Mrs Tanya fayon foreign
minister of Croatia
vice prime minister
radman
[Music]
if there are historical moments special
moments which give us and provide us
with great honor and we witness the
achievement of strategic goals of a
state
this is such a day the first of January
of 2023 the day when Croatia achieved
its stately strategic and political
goals of integration into the Schengen
area and the Eurozone
we are the first country that has done
that in the very same day in the last
six years plus a few months since we
have had the confidence of Croatian
citizens and since we've been at the
head of the government our time was
occupied with getting ready for this
accession and also fulfilling all the
conditions it was the time of very
serious sometimes difficult
foreign policy talks and a lot happened
but we managed to attain our goals with
the full confidence that the Schengen
area and the Eurozone will be beneficial
to Croatian citizens and the Croatian
economy I am particularly pleased that
the president of the commission has
accepted my invitation to come here on a
Sunday the 1st of January she has a
short time with her family but the very
fact that she gave us her time the same
as the Slovenian president I think speak
volumes of the importance of this event
nothing will ever be the same after this
date we see
cars passing through
unimpeded and for Croatia as a tourist
country which
is also an automobile destination to a
great extent that will mean a lot the
fact that we are joining the Eurozone is
another signal to all those coming to
Croatia how welcome they are and this
simplifies their selection of Croatia
as a holiday venue and the selections
are what we do I would also like to
thank the Ministers of the interior of
Foreign Affairs of Finance all members
of the government current and the former
who all contributed to bringing us here
into the deepest integration that we can
belong to 31 years ago we were not
internationally recognized and in only
three decades
since the Liberation over the
temporarily occupied territories of
Croatia for which I now give the
Gratitude again to Croatian War veteran
veterans and without their contribution
we wouldn't have had a state and since
our joining the Union in 2013 and these
two huge steps which have brought us in
the group of 15 countries that belonged
to both Schengen and the Eurozone and
this brings us to the achievement of the
goal defined by the first Croatian
president Dr
franojiman Who's one of the program
points this was Croatia's full-joining
of Europe these processes are now
concluded and the delivery every year
actually also saw the opening of the
parachutes bridge this is a sovereign
mover and we enjoyed the support
of the European Union
357 million euros plus the contribution
of Croatia the participation of
Slovenian Architects this is a wonderful
combination indeed and this is a year in
which we endured all pressures that were
the consequences of the pandemic of the
global crisis
caused by the Russian aggression against
Ukraine we sought solutions for all
pressures energy inflatory and others I
would also like to thank the Croatian
police for having guarded Croatian
borders and I am very happy that now
Croatia can now dedicate its capacities
to the external borders the Schengen
borders 350 kilometers with Serbia
Bosnia and Montenegro without any wires
wire fences or barriers these are the
political principles that we adhere to
and we are very happy that in the past
year Muslim Herzegovina became a
candidate the country and we will not be
separated by barriers or wires we shall
help the Schengen gets stronger we shall
help
bring the euro in and make it become
even more stronger and I would like to
thank the president and the commission I
would like to thank Slovenia former
president Mr pahar and
prime minister golub former Minister
yansha all of them contributed to
Croatia's attainment of these goals
that and I thank all other member states
who gave us their positive vote and they
thank the European Parliament
I'm proud today
thank you prime minister blenkovich now
we give the flow to the president of the
commission Mrs Wonderland prime minister
Madam president Natasha first of all
happy New Year
to the two of you and to everybody here
around us I'm delighted to be with you
here today it is a day to celebrate
it is the season of new beginnings the
1st of January
new chapters that are being opened and
there is no place in Europe whether it
is more true today that it is the season
of new beginnings and new chapters than
here
the border between Croatia and Slovenia
today Croatia joins the Schengen area
and the Eurozone
to immense achievements for the youngest
member
state of the European Union and both
reached on the very same day
so indeed this is a day for the history
books
but above all this is a day of joy and
pride for the creation people
it is testimony of your amazing journey
your hard work and your determination
it is a day of Celebration not only for
Creations but for all European citizens
and from now on internal internal
borders can be crossed freely without
controls like he and bregana and all the
other Crossing points at land with
Slovenia and Hungary at Sea with Italy
and as of March by air with all other
Schengen States
no more checks no more passport controls
no more cues
just people crossing smoothly as we can
see right behind us
tourists visiting Croatia will no longer
need a separate Visa
they can visit with the same Schengen
visa as they use to travel to all other
Schengen countries
the next generation of Creations will
grow up in Schengen
people will be able to travel freely
business will be unhindered by checks
seamless travel will bring tangible
results
for people living along the border
working across the border or having
family on both sides of the Border
communities will grow closer together
and your presence here today Madam
president
clearly shows how important this day is
not just for Croatia but also for all
its neighbors
we will need to work very closely
together to protect Schengen and
preserve its benefits because indeed
Schengen cannot be taken for granted
its functioning has been challenged over
time and it continues to be challenged
Schengen is about commitment
and mutual Trust
in Schengen we rely on each other
and we know that we can trust you
and that we can rely on Croatia
being able to cross internal borders
without controls is one important
achievement
being able to pay cross-borders using
the same EU currency is another one
and I know by my own personal experience
that creations will always remember the
first time they paid with euros
the first time they held the Euro coin
minted with your national emblem the
Kuna
as a symbol of the successful Union
between your national identity and your
European destiny
today you are joining a community of
347 million Europeans
who are using the euro in their everyday
lives
the Euro makes us stronger at home
it facilitates Investments and trade
across borders
thus making our economy more vibrant
it helps to create jobs it brings
macroeconomic stability and credibility
and as the second most important
currency globally
the Euro also makes us stronger on the
world stage
indeed the euro is one of our best
Collective achievements and it is of
course much more than a currency
it is a token of unity
Beyond borders and Beyond languages
Deandre
what an extraordinary success for the
people of Croatia
I know how hard you worked for this day
to come congratulations again
to join the Euro and Schengen
communities just 10 years after Croatia
joined the European Union
this is a day of great pride
of great emotion
and thank you very much for inviting me
to be part of this thank you very much
thank you Mrs fonderlein I now invite
Mrs pets Musa
I also welcome all of you
madam president Mr Prime Minister
I welcome all of you here and this is
indeed my first visit as the president
of Croatia this is a gift to Europe
and it's wonderful to be here with our
neighbors I would like to congratulate
all
Croatian citizens for having joined the
Schengen area and the Eurozone I
congratulate the Croatian government we
know that this was not an easy path and
easy trajectory Mr blinkovich you
deserve to be congratulated for these
achievements and everyone in Croatia can
really be proud of this path that
Croatia has traveled
Madam president of the commission you
also were very attentive to this
process and you encourage others to join
the European Union I as the president of
Slovenia have a full faith in the united
Europe sometimes we may see things
differently but integration is the only
way for the states of Western Balkans
I'm sure that I shall continue the
Slovenian
tradition of assisting States
in the neighborhood to join the
Integrations together with prime
minister blankovich and milanovic and I
would like to say that this is also a
message a message that Europe is our
home and I am convinced that it will
stay so for a very long time it is Our
obligation to defend it to make it a
pleasant for living
in order for us to be equal members of
the great European integration let us
look back
we all know in Slovenia that Primos
truber who founded protestantism in my
country the father of Croatia of
Slovenian literacy we know of that
figure but it is not so well known that
he
helped a great deal to publish and print
books in Croatian in the 16th century
these books were printed in Germany
symbolically this is a connection
between
who helped print and publish books in
Croatian and he was the one who
overcame borders and was led by the idea
of reformation
and we are
led by the idea of United Europe and our
common history can bring us together all
separators and we are the ones who
choose which course to take and I'm
certain that history can only bring us
together bring us closer because
separation
happened all too often in this area in
former Yugoslavia I used to work in
Croatia
and there was in this border that time
as a president of Slovenia I am so happy
on this historical date when Croatia and
Slovenia have no borders between
themselves anymore and when the border
is opened and
it really gives me joy and I am sure
this means a lot no not only
for the Nationals of Slovenia and
Croatia
but um
Slovenian citizens come here for
holidays over a million of them every
year but also it's a two-way street the
croats go to Slovenia to ski in the
winter and uh also work and study in my
country and I said at the very beginning
that this is a great moment for croats
and but it is also a great step for
Slovenia and its Nationals and for my
homeland it is a holiday for them as
well
Mr blankovich my sincere gratitude goes
to you for having invited me to be a
part of this wonderful event at the
border between Croatia and Slovenia and
bregana have become one and I would like
to visit your present Mr milanovic in
future
and um
I would like to ask to draw this path
further
thank you that is all for the media
[Music]